I cannot adequately prepare you for what
we're about to read. That's husband
material to me, lol.
>> [laughter]
>> W- I don't know that we can keep reading
these. This is genuinely making me feel
a little bit ill, dude. This is
genuinely making me feel a little bit
ill. He looks like he has a rotation of
goods. Yeah, I got a rotation of goods.
Or is your mind cannot comprehend. Okay,
so we've got huge updates in the
Nicholas De Oreo, Anisa Jomha drama,
guys. This is This is crazy. Huge
updates, absolutely crazy updates. So,
as you may know,
this all started from Anisa doing an
impression
of
Hila Klein
and her retard-sounding voice.
Saying that Nicholas De Oreo does great
research, which of course is a hilarious
thing to say
that Ethan Hila actually did say because
they because Nick agrees with like 90%
of the [__] that Ethan pushes.
So, that was a pretty funny impression,
pretty funny clip from Anisa that went
around.
And Nick coped about it, said it was
offensive, said it didn't sound anything
like Hila,
and then banged on about
a bunch of stuff about Muslims or
something for like 5 minutes. And it was
just like absolutely excruciating to
watch.
Now, we have a brand new updates in this
story.
Let's first see
what was Anisa saying on Twitter.
over the last day or two.
There are many beautiful fat people who
they never left their with a microphone
and Nick De Oreo and showing compare
faces and 84% match and then they show
this edited photo of Nick and girl with
a microphone half split and trick
reference says Ethan Klein is the most
fat-phobic dude alive. How are they even
trying to make this argument? I saw H3
fans within the last month that claimed
that Anisa couldn't have had an eating
disorder because she's not thin enough.
Excuse me for not taking their cries of
fat-phobia seriously. In a burrito ham
says, are these people dumb or just
stupid? They don't understand how
anything works like at all. No one they
fall into cults so easily. Lurk er says,
Hila hates
>> So, this is absolutely just true, by the
way. This is just like what we're
talking about in the comments. I don't
care about stuff, but that is absolutely
just true about H3 and the fans
is they are fine with using absolutely
any attack against people. There's
There's no standards. And they turn
around and it really is It's curious
just sort of like cry out, you know,
when they get hit back. It's interesting
how that happens, guys. They They just
start crying out. They cry foul the
moment that the moment they get struck
back, they start crying foul. It's
interesting. It's very interesting,
guys.
It's fat people. It's why Ethan is on
Ozempic and starting to prescribe
>> is like that
They They're attacking you, and all of a
sudden they're crying, and you've got no
idea why. It's like
you know, you you got a little bit in
the crossfire here.
And it's also very odd but not
surprising that she's defending a racist
Chad who hosts rape reviews, laughing at
essays on women, not a girls girl. She's
a pick me for incels. And I see Mary and
Barry replies and still doesn't have a
man, I think, lol. And Captain Kingpao
says, microphone girl is a lesbian.
Anisa then replies to girl with a
microphone's post and replies by quote
tweeting it and saying, there are many
beautiful fat people who love their
bodies. He isn't one of them, and
neither are you with that fuck-ass bun
you choose to wear every day. Bro's
ankles look like they've been pumped
with assault and he needs a lymphatic
drainage stat. He looks like he has a
rotation of goods that are all beige in
color. That's not my problem.
Micronutrients matter. Love your body.
Take a multivitamin. It all corrected
foods to goods. Thanks for that iPhone.
And Tay was taken replies to Anisa by
saying, you are such a mean and hateful
[__] Oh my god. Yeah.
W, hello, W.
That's awesome.
That's peak. We love that.
And Andy says, you're a disgusting
excuse of a person.
How many more [music] losses to Anisa do
you think it would be before Nick starts
calling himself trans or non-binary
again? Maybe Hila will try another
makeup drop and he'll come out again
with some bogie tier stuff. Thank you.
Thank you for the donate. Thank you.
person. You and your musty-ass husband
are always concerning yourselves with
other people's lives when you really
should be concerned with getting an
infection from never washing your ass.
Go take a shower, nasty bitter [__]
Mike replies to Anisa by saying, Anisa
>> And look how [__] mad these people
get, bro. Look how mad they all get. her
mean girl bully era. And honestly, I
don't mind it. Hot take, but I think if
you're hot and skinny enough, you're
allowed to be a bully to a certain
degree. She's done the work to look the
way she does. So, she kind of has some
authority on the subject of healthy
bodies. Leslie Dessu says, me when I'm a
pathetic-ass [__] with no substantial
criticism, so I just resort to being
fat-phobic and bullying people based on
appearances even though I'm covered in
fuck-ass tattoos and my husband looks
like he crawled out of Dobby's [__]
And girl with a microphone screenshots
Anisa's post and captions it by saying,
one, cool insult about my hair from your
favorite snark subreddits. I love my
fuck-ass bun. Two, Anisa Jomha is
deciding which fat people are pretty
enough to talk. Line up, tubbos. Three,
You're just talking You're talking about
my bun cuz snark Dude,
no, it's because it looks [__]
disgusting and greasy, actually. That's
why. I have yet to say a single thing
about your looks because I'm not
mentally stunted at 13. And Harley
Morenstein replies, wow, she is so
pissed. Shauna says replies to the girl
with a microphone by saying, I am nearly
as fat as you. Do you think Hila, who
fat-shamed her own husband is so
relentlessly on air he became a rotting
skeleton, hasn't said worse about you?
P.S. You should not be happy with that
matted rat's nest. I would put money on
mold being in there. And girl with a
microphone replies, oof, this is so sad.
She also makes a follow-up post
separately saying, Dude, how it was
legit. You know
Glam is just like beyond help because
Nick does not even attempt to stick his
neck out for her.
You know.
It You You might even see Nick slightly
step out for Harley once in a while,
but never for Glam. Never for Glam.
another woman's hair and body in 2026 is
so [__] rotted and stupid. Like how
miserable are you, girl? And Dish
replies to this post of Fram a girl with
a microphone in the caption, yeah.
Imagine commenting on someone's looks in
2026, right? And it's her quote tweeting
a post from a few days ago where she
said, anyone else ever notice these
people only laugh when they're being
ugly and cruel? And the girl with a
microphone replies, oh no, guys, he
can't read. And Dish says, glad I got
your attention. Can you address your
>> I was using ugly to talk about their
behavior, actually. Right. A host
starring in a transphobic music video.
Hope you can address that in your
aftershow instead of covering week-old
celebrity news. Thanks. Okay, Mammoth
also posted in the H3H3 Productions
subreddit the interaction of Anisa and
captions it by saying, but he's not
Frogan, so it's okay. He looks like he
showers, has clean hair, brushes his
teeth, and doesn't have rancid mango
breath and trailer park tattoos. I would
say so, of course he isn't her type. But
then again, neither is Ian. Also, Ian
should be tending to her caretaker
duties by making sure the dragon doesn't
accidentally drown in the tub or
something.
>> some more on this, okay, guys. We got
some more on this. This was like a good
jumping-off point.
You want to make me feel sick.
Dude, this is peak, bro.
This might be an all-time Reddit post.
The H3 girlies are all over Nicholas.
Fire emoji, fire emoji.
Guys,
I cannot prepare you for what we're
about to read.
I cannot adequately prepare you for what
we're about to read.
Okay, listen. I've always thought he was
kind of hot.
People really underestimate how being
happy is a factor in their
attractiveness. Most people don't want
to be around miserable people. So, you
see someone smiling and laughing, it's
way more attractive than crying on a
stream. Guys, someone Someone please
post the video of
uh
Tom and Augie following him around
playing the [__] Family Guy theme
music at him. And he's just got like
this [__] his face just drops. Just
has like this
It's so [__] good, dude.
It's so [__] good.
This is genuinely so true. I don't know
if anyone else is an LPOTL fan.
Someone's going to have to tell me what
that is.
All those three guys all have super hot
wives and joke about how they're out of
their league.
But it's because humor and personality
matter a lot when it comes to being
attractive.
Are we sure that the success I feel like
if you know who these people are, it's
probably more likely that it's because
they're very successful.
I'm just going to go out on a limb.
So, it's probably a bigger factor in
this.
Why? He's funny, charismatic, clever,
has three dogs, holds down a full-time
job, and streams. Seems like a
high-value male to me.
The red pill terminology for why
Nick De Oreo is a catch. Bro, I can't. I
can't.
I'm experiencing
like a [__] aneurysm or something.
>> [laughter]
>> That's husband material to me, lol.
>> Oh my god.
>> [laughter]
>> There's something about
a New York Italian
that's just Yes, please, dude.
W- I don't know that we can keep reading
these. This is genuinely making me feel
a little bit ill, dude. This is
genuinely making me feel a little bit
ill.
I can agree. I always love seeing him on
his rare cam streams. Joey is saying
Nicholas is handsome, lol. I agree. I
agree.
Same.
Glad to know I'm not alone.
Respectfully, sometimes I have no idea
what he's even talking about, but I just
like listening to him, lol. I think he's
totally attractive and has so much going
for him.
I think it's most viewers. I don't think
anyone's really paying attention to
what's being said. I don't think there's
There's any way he would have 3,000-plus
viewers if they were, frankly.
Christ, I can't shut up, but I'm
married, so I won't be too thirsty, but
Nick DeOrio has a very nice sounding
voice. Fire.
And so we've got
someone's um
gone through a few of these accounts and
found some posts.
So it seems like one of these people
saying um HSV1 is not genital herpes.
My 20 female boyfriend, 42 male, and I
have been together for a few months, and
it's genuinely the happiest I've ever
been. Doesn't bother me too much, but
sometimes the weird comments from people
get really annoying. Oh, he's using you
for sex and you're using him for money,
I don't know. I hope all of this proves
my relationship is valid. People have
the wrong idea. So unfortunately people
are so judgmental about things that
don't involve them.
I just found out it's not normal to have
voices. I'm diagnosed bipolar disorder
unspecified.
That was on I don't even listen.
I've spoken to a lot of
fried people.
I've never heard of this
psychoactive drug before.
What the [__] is
lamotrigine?
What the [__] is that?
What on earth is that? And Lexapro for a
few months around November to January
2023.
Life-changing.
I got the rash from lamotrigine. He took
me off everything, gave me
Okay.
I got top surgery around 2 years ago.
I'm a gender non-conforming trans guy.
And then guys,
I'm a soft body trans man.
You can't make it up, bro. You can't
make it up.
You cannot [__] make it up.
Aggressive expert replies. It's got to
kill her that this guy's hitting home
run after home run every day because she
can't help but embarrass herself online.
And Breaky Show says, he's making more
money than her online and at his day
job. I would be coping and seething,
too. And Mikey Rubbertoe says, "And
never forget that there was a time,
maybe still applies, when Nick was
making more money from Twitch than
iDubbz, despite never even going live,
just from people
>> Why would you get in a plane with her if
I'm supposed to agree with you? Well, I
didn't do well out. I didn't do well
out. going to his inactive account as a
joke. Spooge McDuck says, "Nick is also
very talented humor. He is quick-witted,
speaks fast, yet clearly, is funny and
charismatic, and most of all, I believe
what he is saying. I don't agree with
him on everything and don't appreciate
some of his points, but I'd much rather
hang with him because I would have a
much better time with him than Ian and
Anisa. Based on what I've seen from him,
he seems to listen to reasonable
arguments and can change his mind on
things, which puts him miles ahead of
Ian and Anisa." And Tofa L replies, "I
definitely agree. Meanwhile, iDubbz's
streams are by their nature pretty
[__] boring. I wonder why Nick gets
more viewers than iDubbz." And Tolerant
Drama Retiree attaches a thread of
comments from the thread we were just on
on the clipped live subreddit.
>> mate is funny.
There's no way this is in the video,
bro.
And there's multiple comments here. It
starts with a Loving Disease saying,
"Okay, listen,
I thought he's kind of hot." And
Espionage says, "People really
underestimate how being happy is a
factor in their attractiveness. Most
people don't want to be around miserable
people. So when you see Oh yeah, here's
the here's that.
Blast that [__] You can go louder.
It's so quiet. This is not working.
>> louder tuba music. You're going to play
tuba music and film you walking.
>> Guys, guys, look at his face, man. Blast
that [__] You can go louder. Just
getting relentlessly bullied.
Crazy, bro.
Seeing someone smiling and laughing is a
way more attractive than crying on a
stream. And Felicity Foxen says, "This
is genuinely so true. I don't know if
anyone else is an LPOTL fan, but those
three guys all have super hot wives and
joke about how they're out of their
league, but it's because humor and
personality matter a lot when it comes
to being attracted to
>> Did anyone else just What is LPOTL? What
is that?
>> someone." And Finnwick and Charlie
Clarker says, "Right? He's funny and
charismatic, clever, has three dogs, he
holds down a full-time job, and streams.
Seems like a high-value
>> Oh, wait, isn't
Last Podcast on the left. That's him.
Right. Okay. you mail to me." And
Felicity Foxen says, "That's husband
material to me." And Private Message Me
Anus Photos replies, "There's something
about a New York Italian that's just
yes, please." Then unrelated, there was
another tweet that went viral of someone
photoshopping themselves with AI and a
girl. And J Sal quote tweeted this post.
Hello, my name is something mid like
Melissa. I'm 42 and I love only three
things: ramen, Shawn pizza, trips to the
Nick DeOrio, and trauma dumping about a
miscarriage I had in high school.
Thank you for the $10. Thank you. And
instead photoshopped Anisa and Nicholas
DeOrio with AI and the caption, "This
could be us. Look how happy you look."
And Neo Slacker replies, "Her hands on
his soft midsection has me [__]
rolling." Anisa then replies to this
image by saying, "Stop. Why is this on
my timeline? Get this off my timeline. I
have to block you. I don't even know
you." And Scott replies, "You hate
having the most dangerous and baddest
[__] in the game. You should drop that
creepy loser who refuses to keep you
online and get with a king like this."
And Anisa replies with a emoji and a
peace emoji. She then also says, "I
can't stop laughing. I should have never
tweeted about this freak. My timeline
has been ruined. My god." Eek then
tweets out this clip of the
conversation. Nicholas DeOrio responds
after Anisa calls him out on the topic.
Guys, this is it. This is it. Nicholas
DeOrio has given us
cinema today, okay?
His response to Anisa making fun of him.
Guys, you are not ready. You are not
ready for this, okay? Let's go back into
this.
timeline, saying they privated by
Instagram over this drama. Like I have
now privated by Instagram. Not true. My
Instagram was privated during the doxing
drama that the people who are mad about
this tried to say it didn't happen
during the turkey tom situation. Dude,
it's like legit the people who are mad
about this. It's like everyone who's
ever spoken bad about Nick DeOrio is one
group. It's so [__] crazy, dude.
Thank you, Connie, for the membership.
Thank you.
My Instagram's been privated for over a
month. I was considering unprivate
privating it, but I don't use it enough
to really justify it being a social
platform.
>> Nick DeOrio is out there telling people
Gamma is my top guy. This has to be
stopped. We have to put an end to this.
Nick DeOrio is out there smearing me
saying implying Gamma is like my top
guy.
We have to We have to put a stop to
this.
Thank you for the 5 lbs weed. Thank you.
Huge appreciate. Thank you.
Thanks for cigarette funds. So my stream
never gains the appetite to be more like
Nick. Thank you.
platform.
Um
then Anisa said, "Bro's ankles, dude.
Look at these ankles. Look like they've
been pumped with salts and he needs a
lymph lymphatic drainage stat. He looks
like he has a rotation of goods. Yeah, I
got a rotation of goods uh that are all
beige
When does this guy
ever not sound like a rapist when saying
something sexual or derisive towards
women?
How does this guy manage to always sound
like he is
two drinks away from pushing past the
pushing past the boundary?
What is this guy's problem?
It makes the hair on the back of my neck
stand up, bro.
Asian color. I guess that means foods.
She had the ability to edit this, I
think. That's not my problem.
Micronutrients matter. Love your body.
Take a multivitamin. So it wasn't a
multivitamin. I
>> Thank you, Heidi, for the $5. Thank you.
Huge appreciate. Thanks so much.
lost 100 lbs. That kind of cleared up
the whole leg thing, but I appreciate
your courtesy. And listen, all right?
>> Okay, show legs.
>> lose weight. Show ankles.
>> You could regrow your hair, you know? If
you really It's like guys, guys, so
we've already got an amazing rapey Nick
moment. I'll see you there. So it wasn't
a multivitamin. I just lost 100 lbs.
That that kind of cleared up the whole
leg thing, but I appreciate your
courtesy. And listen, all right?
You could lose weight.
You could regrow your hair, you know? If
you really Listen, I think around the
time this photo was taken, you were like
a bald little boy, right? Because you
you got Pipo sad and shaved your head
like Britney Spears. Wasn't that what
you were doing, Mrs. I Wish I Was
Pretty?
I wish I felt pretty. It wasn't I Wish I
Was Pretty. I wish I felt pretty.
Yeah, but I mean, the reality of the
situation is you could lose some weight.
I need to lose some weight. I'm still a
person of calorie. And you could regrow
your hair. I think it looks fine now.
>> It's like what He's not even making
jokes. He's just on an extended pissed
off rant about how she looks. There's
not even jokes being made. He's not
rolling with it.
It's like he's just seething. He's just
[__] mad, dude. It's so funny. I
can't believe he got on stream and did
this
about [__] Anisa.
These are meant to be all locals, bro.
These are meant to be all locals.
What's happening, man?
What's going on, bro?
public platform. Um
then Anisa said, "Bro's ankles, dude.
Look at these ankles.
>> Let's run this back.
>> they've been pumped with salts and he
needs a lymph lymphatic drainage stat.
He looks like he has a rotation of
goods. Yeah, I got a rotation of goods
uh that are all beige in color. I guess
that means foods. She had the ability to
edit this, I think. That's not my
problem. Micronutrients matter. Love
your body.
>> Don't you know you can edit posts with
Twitter Blue? Okay, get with the [__]
rest, dude. You take a multivitamin. So
it wasn't a multivitamin. I just lost
100 lbs. That that kind of cleared up
the whole leg thing, but I appreciate
your courtesy. And listen, all right?
You could lose weight.
You could regrow your hair, you know? If
you really Listen, I think around the
time this photo was taken, you were like
a bald little boy, right? Because you
you got Pipo sad and shaved your head
like Britney Spears. Wasn't that what
you were doing, Mrs. I Wish I Was
Pretty?
I wish I felt pretty. It wasn't I wish I
was pretty. I wish I felt pretty.
Yeah, but I mean the reality of the
situation is you could lose some weight.
I need to lose some weight. I'm still a
person of calorie and you can regrow
your hair. I think it looks fine now.
But
the tattoos the tattoos are here
forever. And [__] doodles from Miles
Morales' notebook.
>> THIS IS AWFUL.
>> GET IT. IF YOU sue the person who did
your tattoos for [__] damages, then I
think that Ethan would fund the lawsuit.
That would be based. I like this one.
The the the proportions.
>> all of iDubbbz' money on buying boobs,
deboobing them, and
Anissa is DeOrion's personally run. He
never expected her to retaliate. Now
he's flailing calling out for allies.
Thank you for the $5. Thank you. Thank
you.
It's so tough to get through, man. It's
so tough to get through. And yeah, dude.
It's so funny how but I can sit here,
you know, we're free. You know, I'm free
I'm my mind is free. My my uh
My speech is is totally free. I can sit
here. I can say
yeah, and Anissa and Ian look kind of
trashy with all their tattoos. I'm not a
big fan of tattoos at the best of times.
But yeah, they're like laying like
tribal [__] and all this like endless
just [__]
smearing ink all over your body looks
like [__]
Ethan's tattoos
are exceptionally
bad.
Ethan's tattoo of Heela
the tattoo he got of Heela
it cannot be put into words.
It's like otherworldly scary. It's like
this
this Eldritch interpretation of his
wife, you know. Just
ho
horrors your mind cannot comprehend.
Just that the absolute abyss behind her
eyes.
Send me the Send me the tattoo. Send me
the tattoo or put it up.
And he never says a word about that
[__] And he never says a word about it.
Where is the Where's the tattoo? Someone
send me the tattoo I'll pull it up. Here
we go. Bro.
Like what on earth is this thing, dude?
What on earth was he thinking? And he
gets so Ethan
endlessly [__] talks other people's
tattoos and how other people look.
It's crazy. And And they don't say
anything about it. They all just sit
there. They all just sit there and let
him do it. No one says oh yo, Ethan. You
You have got like that picture that one
tattooed picture of your wife that
somehow makes her look even uglier.
It's kind of a Ethan. We might want to
just take it easy. We have what Is that
very unflattering image of your wife
that you've got permanently etched into
your skin?
Filling your body with the ugliest
tattoos anyone's ever seen in their
lives. Remember weight can be lost.
>> Certainly not the ugliest.
Hair can be grown back. But come on.
doodles from Miles
>> is awful.
>> GET IT.
IF YOU SUE THE PERSON who did your
tattoos for [__] damages, then I
think that Ethan would fund the lawsuit.
That would be based.
>> I like this one.
The proportions.
>> You spent all of iDubbbz' money on
buying boobs, deboobing them, and
filling your body with the ugliest
tattoos anyone's ever seen in their
lives. Remember weight can be lost. Hair
can be grown back. But your body is
ravaged forever. Anyway I think we have
one more thing to check out here. Oh,
yeah, that's the other part, dude. You
know who caught the biggest stray in
this entire drama? This is like the
Cathal's thing which we found out that
everyone thinks she's [__] ugly.
Frogan just found out
>> It's like, bro, it's crazy. I've I get
told I I'm like deranged and so insane I
just have like no limits and whatever.
Guys, how many jokes did I make about
Aride's obvious terrible boob job?
Like it was incredibly rare if I ever
mentioned it. In fact, I oftentimes I
think I got, you know, I've got like
guys, can we not just bang on about the
obvious boob job?
Okay, can we not just bang on about
that? It's really quite annoying seeing
my chat talk about that. It makes you
look all a little bit strange.
So
you know, I I feel like I get quite a
bad rap. Oh, these things. I get quite a
bad rap. But I actually do pull punches
on [__] that's just kind of weird to go
in on. Like why are you going on about
this one's boob job? What's going on,
man?
What's going on? What's happening here?
out that all of her friends think that
she's disgusting. That's the funniest
part of this entire drama.
I mean I literally
>> down on chat like a [__] bus kill
fascist about all our awesome jokes.
Guys, I've been getting called fat for 7
years. But Frogan just found out that
all of her friends [__] think she's
pathetic and gross. That's the funniest
[__] ever.
That is actually the funniest [__]
take is that everybody legitimately Like
she found out yesterday
that all of her
>> Yeah, I'm sure that's the first time
Frogan has ever heard one of her friends
make a fat joke.
What [__] world are you living in,
Nick? What [__] planet are you living
on, bro? Seriously. How does this land?
How does this land with anyone? Oh,
Anissa's talking [__] about me. Oh oh
oh, Frogan Frogan. He can't even hit
back. Like he's not confident any of the
hits that he's he's swung back with.
So it's just like oh oh, Frogan Frogan.
Bro, she's like not even relevant. When
does Frogan ever mentioned anymore?
Frogan's not in any of the [__]
drama. When does she ever show up on
streams or anything, bro? She's totally
irrelevant.
her friends think she's gross.
>> [laughter]
>> And Proxy replies again with the sleepy
clip we looked at earlier of the friend
zoning. And Congress Amongus replies,
"Qu- Qu- quick, he's flaming her. Bring
out the 2019 files." And Y R World Tour
says, "An anime avatar that thinks being
friend zoned in 2019 is some big expose.
Yeah, that tracks." Night Kitten says,
"Damn, I hate DeOrion, but everyone he
beefs with is a two chronically wrong
and retard."
I mean, they are right to that person is
[__]
All I'm going to say is when your chin
and neck are on one, then you can equate
yourself to me, Lmao. Let's go pound for
pound. I will bring my scale out. You
bring yours. We're going to get some
McFlurry. I know you want badly, you fat
[__]
So I mean Frogan's like not they're
typically very funny and this is not
lying to me. I'm not going to lie.
Go back to talking [__] on vets. That's
when you were [__] awesome. That's
when you were That's when you were
saying epic stuff, okay? Go back to
talking [__] on vets. But yeah, I mean,
listen, she's [__] glamming DeOrion,
so I'm not even part of this [__] Keep
my name out your damn mouths. I never
fat shame anybody. If you're going to
come after me for my weight and how I
look and you look like that, get the
[__] out of here, Lmao. I mean, that's
not too bad. That's fine.
This what you should you should have
just tweeted this.
So yeah, pretty shameful stuff [music]
here from Nicholas DeOrion.